can we say amen again
will you be able to stand
that's a very serious question
revelation 6 the last verse of that
chapter says
for the great day of his wrath is come
and who shall be able to stand
of course chapter 7 answers that
question by identifying those who have
the seal of god
in their foreheads thank you brother
neville very much
for your contribution to the worship
service
good evening everyone how do you do
i'm pleased to see you and i'm pleased
to see by faith
those who are joining us by the internet
may god bless us all as we enter into
the final
plenary session am i correct of this
very blessed weekend and i say a very
blessed weekend because it has been that
for me
and i can only speak for myself if it
has been that for you go right ahead and
say amen
whenever we're in the presence of god it
ought to be a blessed experience
and so i publicly thank god for granting
me this
opportunity i like to say when it comes
across my mind
i like to say it publicly that god has
always been good to me he has never
done me anything wrong never
every blessing in my life has come from
god
every problem hardship heartache
hernia heartburn
i have brought on myself so i want to
clear god's name of any wrongdoing in my
life god
has never never
done me anything wrong
and if you have held the feeling that he
has done you something wrong
you should submit to the impulsive
honesty and tell god you're sorry
the lord is righteous in all his ways
and holy
in all his works psalm 145 verse 17
god does nothing wrong
i just love to say that to give god his
credit
is anyone joining us for the first time
this weekend may i see your hands first
time
first time just raise your hand god
bless you
god bless you god bless you god bless
you anyone else
god bless you and god bless you my
brother i believe i saw you raise your
hand
question two is there anyone with us who
is not a
seventh-day adventist may i see your
hand
you are not a seventh-day adventist
raise your hand
no one is there anyone in the overflow
room or we don't need that now
no one answered the preacher is there
anyone
in the overflow room no all right okay
so no
non-seventh-day adventists with us let
me offer a polite suggestion
based on two simple stories one
i was in kampala the capital of uganda
to conduct a crusade
or evangelistic campaign
and i was staying in a hotel and i came
down to the lobby for one reason or
another
all evangelists are very nosy people and
so
i i saw a young lady i said who are you
why are you here
and she said my name is lydia and she
told me what she was doing
she worked for the armed forces and she
was guarding a diplomat who was staying
in that hotel
but she was off duty and a fellow female
soldier was guarding the diplomat in her
room then she said who are you and what
are you doing and i told her
i told her i want you to come
she said i'd love to come but i have no
transportation i said there's a car that
picks me up every day at 5 30 you'll be
ready in this lobby at 5 30 i'll take
you with me
she came got baptized
i was in uganda april may i saw her
very faithful in the church
how did it happen
all i did was to do what invite
that's all i was in dar es salaam
the largest city in tanzania for a
similar reason evangelistic campaign
and i like going to the gym to work out
because the bible is heavy are you with
me
and so i
and so i went looking for a gym and i
had
one of the elders of the local church
was with me and we found the gym loved
the little gym
and we went in there was a receptionist
and they speak swahili in tanzania so i
told him tell her
why i am here in her country tell her
i as the speaker want her to come
she said i'll come she spoke english
she came the same night first night
came every night finish the story come
on finish the story
god baptized come on somebody say amen
how did it happen give me one word
invitation
that's all some people say i cannot give
a bible study
i don't know the bible that well i'm not
mark finley or doug batchelor david
ashwick or
scott moore
no no no but do you know someone who
knows the bible
then you can tell someone i know someone
who can explain the bible to you
why am i going on about this because i'm
rebuking you that there are no
non-seventh-day adventists in this
congregation
and you went out all afternoon
you must have knocked on some door with
a man who had nothing else to do
always try to have guests in your
services
that's why the church exists
isn't this called life
do you repent all right
you know wherever i go i always ask
where are the nonsense
no hands
no hands what's the great gospel
commission
going therefore and teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost
teaching them to observe
all things whatsoever i have commanded
you go
and compel them to come in
so please please please
at your local churches make a commitment
we will try to have visitors every
sabbath
i don't mean to prolong the story but
let me make it very practical
do you know how many young people are in
prison because another young person said
let's go rob a store
let's take some dope
let's sneak into a club with some fake
id
now you take the same energy and you
simply say let's go to church
sister i'm so glad you're with me
sometimes because nobody else says
anything
i'll miss you when i leave tomorrow
morning god bless you
the rest of you i rebuke you
so nice to rebuke good looking people
it's so easy but you know
we get people into trouble all the time
let's get them out of trouble instead of
saying let's go to the club
let's go to aoi
that's all what are you doing wednesday
night
uh let's go to a service
we're doing on sabbath afternoon what do
you mean by sabbath
then you have a chance to explain are
you with me
what are you doing i'm on facebook come
here
and listen to a presentation on
something or another
when you invite someone you can get one
of two possible answers
yes or no
that's all all right
i've rebuked you enough
uh are you okay those of you by the
internet
i was also rebuking you so don't feel
because i'm sure in your church there
were no visitors today probably
always populate your congregation with
visitors all intelligent peoples amen
all right do three favors for me before
i begin favor number one what is that
yes and i brought mine so i can give you
a visual
visual symbol of cooperation mine is
already off
by the way it doesn't ring so there's no
point in turning it off or on but i just
wanted to show you the pulpit is
cooperating
number two while i'm speaking pray for
me and all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth
you know in ii samuel 23 2 david said
the spirit of the lord spake by me and
his word was in my tongue
i want god's word in the very instrument
of speech
my tongue and faith number three
i want you to think let's pray
loving father in heaven we thank you
today god for the
access we have to you as amazing as it
may be
and almost impossible to believe
through christ and the indwelling of his
spirit
we can be closer to you than adam was
in his sinless state ah father help us
to contemplate these
mighty themes that our minds may become
more spiritual
and heaven focused as i deliver this
final message father
i humble myself before you my desire
is to glorify your name and to make the
message clear and
simple so father put your words in my
mouth
in my heart and let the spirit using me
be the
sense of self-same spirit that touches
every listening heart in this building
and by the internet
let us leave at the conclusion of this
service with the confidence
the certainty unshakable that we have
met with our god
please father answer this prayer
according to your will
because i have offered it in the name of
jesus christ and on the basis of his
infinite sacrifice
let all god's people say amen and amen
genesis chapter six or chapter seven
reading from verse one well let's go to
six we'll read from verse five
genesis 6 reading from verse
let's read in verse 1. some of us don't
read the bible often enough
we read from verse 1 of genesis 6. the
bible says and it came to pass when men
began to multiply on the face of the
earth
and daughters were born unto them that
the sons of god saw the daughters of men
that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose and the lord said
my spirit shall not always strive with
man
for that he also is flesh yet his day
shall be 120 years there were giants in
the earth in those days and also after
that when the sons of god came in unto
the daughters of men
and they bear children to them the same
became mighty men
which were of old men of renown read
verse 5 with me
and god saw that the wickedness of man
was
great in the earth and that every
imagination of the faults of his heart
was only evil continually verse 6
and it repented the lord that he had
made man on the earth
and he grieved him at his heart
you think god suffers pain do you think
god suffers pain
yes a pain you and i will never
understand
and i have a suspicion just a private
suspicion
god will suffer some degree of pain
forever
the pain he will feel for those who were
lost
even though he was not willing that any
should perish
listen to verse 6 of genesis 6
i mean really listen and read the word
microscopically
and it repented the lord
he in his own way i don't claim to
understand fully god in his own way
he regretted
that he had made man on the earth
question for you don't answer me
god looks down on us and he sees the
life we led today
the life we led this past week the past
six months
is god regretting allowing us to live
is god saying you know i should have
taken the breath of life from that man
last night
i would not be suffering the
embarrassment i am now
or maybe not that severe are we causing
god to be
grieved at his heart by the way we live
put your mind grasp imagine
it grieved him at his heart what's the
expression on god's face
what's the expression as he feels this
grief
looking at the lives of the only aspect
of creation
made in his image eloise says
man was a brand new species because he
was made in god's image
the lord said i will destroy man whom
i've created from the face of the earth
both man and beast the creeping things
and the files of the air for it
repenteth me
that i have made them
but noah somebody say amen for noah
but noah found grace in the eyes
of the lord
why only noah
we're talking about an entire world
only noah
all of the faithful people have passed
away of those
alive on the earth
just before the flood came only noah
and his family
i urge you again use your imagination
one family
on the entire world god sees
that he can save now let's go to chapter
seven let's read verse one
someone asked me what's the title i have
none
if you make up one you can use it
genesis 7 reading first one the bible
says and the lord
said unto noah come thou brother ben
is it ben good to see you again god
bless you
he was here this morning come on say
something
what was the name of the other visitor
donna this is been
sister dawn of god bless her river
ben thanks for coming back
genesis 7 verse 1 the bible says and the
lord
said unto noah read with me
come thou and all thy house into the
ark for thee have i seen righteous
before me
in this generation
in this era this epoch
of the earth's history i have found one
family
noah sister noah his three sons
and the three wives of the three boys
eight
righteous people
what did jesus say as it was in the days
of noah
it doesn't mean they'll necessarily be
just eight at the end but few
eight
let's leapfrog from genesis 8 7 let's go
to genesis 12.
we read from verse 1 of genesis 12.
remember genesis 12 immediately follows
genesis 11
which is a story of what the tower of
babel
where all the nations came together all
the people
to live one place led by whom
nimrod a descendant of whom
cain let's give noah some slack
cain a descendant of
cain the very first city built was built
by cain
he named it after a son called enoch not
the enoch who walked with god by the way
and when the descendants of cain built
the first kingdom
and the beginning of his kingdom was
babel and eric an academy in the line of
shiner
genesis 10 verse 10 11 i believe it is
and so in this
whirlpool of iniquity
rebellion against god i mean high-handed
rebellion
god found one of the family
the family of noah
not the entire family of noah i'm not no
sorry correct me
abraham not the entire family of abraham
just abraham
because the bible says in joshua 24 2
and i took your father abraham
from the other side and said why they
served other gods
they mingle truth with error and when
you put one drop of strychnine
into one glass of orange juice you don't
drink any of it
for truth to be truth it has to be pure
because truth is a quality of god and
there's nothing impure about god
and so god saw abraham as the only one
faithful to that which descended from
adam
to shem and that holy line
enoch down through noah
the bible says in genesis 12 reading
from verse 1
now the lord had said unto abram get
thee out of thy country
and from thy kindred and from thy
father's house unto a land that i
will show thee and we read that this
morning
and i will make of thee a great nation
and i will bless thee and make thy name
great and thou
shalt be a blessing a blessing to whom
the rest of the world as the verse will
tell us and i will bless them that bless
thee
and curse him that curse of thee and in
shall all families of the earth be
blessed
god looked on the earth and
found one steadfast faithful family
a similar occurrence in the days of noah
you're looking at me should i assume
you're listening
i said hundreds of years later god is
facing the same scenario
one faithful family
and god calls him
from his own family
did you hear what i said he calls him
patriarchs and prophets page 126
paragraph 1
in order that god might qualify him for
his great work as the keeper of the
sacred articles
abraham must be separated from the
associations of his early life
the influence of kindred and friends
would interfere
with the training the lord purposed to
give his servant
now that abraham was in a certain sense
connected with heaven
he must dwell among strangers his
character must be peculiar
differing from all the world so we've
got two groups the world and abraham
he could not even explain his course of
action
so as to be understood by his friends
spiritual things
are spiritually discerned and his
motives and actions were not
comprehended
by his idolatrous kindred listen to me
when you get close to god your
family will not understand church
members will not understand
your sharpest persecution will come from
the church
jesus was preaching in a house crowded
with people eager for the gospel
his family came to seize him mark 3 21
they said he is beside himself man
nuts
could not understand
god found one family the family of
abraham
in the days of noah one family
in the days of abraham one family
let's skip a few thousand years
coming out of the 1840s
if you regard groups of nations as
families this nation is a family
or each church is a family
there was a message preached in the
1840s
which is found in revelation 14 verse 8
and they followed another angel saying
babylon is fallen
is fallen babylon fallen that great city
why because she made all nations drink
of the wine
of the wrath of a fornication without
going into detail
babylon is a symbolic uh representation
of
false religion now
this message was preached way back in
the 1840s that babylon not
is falling is fallen
listen to me carefully
churches opposed to god's law have been
in a fallen condition
for 150 something years
there are some churches some of our
young people run to you're running into
a building that's collapsing
you run out of that kind of building
and with all these churches fallen
god looked around
found a small group
who's decided to take a closer look at
the word of god
and realized something happened in the
sanctuary above
realize there's something called the
sabbath that god still requires
realize that there's something called
when you're dead you're dead
realize that the gift of prophecy still
existed in the church
realize the key to explaining scripture
and salvation the plan of the gospel is
the sanctuary and they realized that
christ would come back
and as they studied they formed
themselves
into a little family
of all the religious families on the
face of the earth
god found one
faithful to the bible
one made up of ostracized members from
other groups
and from that one that group of perhaps
out of the thousands that were waiting
for christ to come october 22 1844 from
that small group
while all the others went back to their
old churches or just gave up religion
all together
or slid into fanaticism
this small group going back to god's
word
had the understanding clarified
and they studied they had sabbath
conferences
they studied they pounded out the
doctrines
sometimes they studied all night they
would cry
if they desire to understand
where was the last time you cried
because you could not understand
they would cry they wanted to understand
after a few years and the doctrines
became crystallized they began spreading
it
spreading it spreading it spreading it
and the realization came upon them by
god's leading
for the work to be effective and to
spread they needed to organize
themselves
and the first sort of recognized
organizational unit was called
the michigan conference somebody say
amen for the michigan
in 1860 three years later they formed
what
the general conference we just
celebrated 150 years
i think it was may 17 or something
but they needed a name
and some of these well-meaning people
came up with all kinds of funny sounding
names
and then god sent them a name
you know god believes in names
to him that overcometh will i give to
eat of the hidden manner
and will give him a white stone and in
the stone a new name written which no
man knoweth saveth he that receiveth it
god is a god who likes to give names
and he said unto him genesis 32 27 what
is thy name and he said jacob and he
said thy name shall be called no more
jacob
but israel for as a prince has thou
overcome with god and man
as thou triumph with god in man and
overcome now god
changes names genesis 7 and 5 that thy
name shall be called no more abram but
abraham
for father of many nations have i made
thee genesis 17 15
as for syria thy wife thou shalt not
call her name
syria but sarah
she shall bring forth a son and thou
shalt call his name
jesus why for he shall save his people
from their sins
god knocked him off the horse when he
hit the ground his name was saul
when he rose up his name was paul
god changes names he gives names are you
with me
god said this faithful people they need
a name
you know the name god gave them
seventh-day
adventists my subject for today what is
your name
sister where my sister there's your
title
testimonies volume one page 223
paragraph
one listen carefully
i was shown
when you read i was shown that's when
you sit up
and you turn off the tv you can't miss
this this is the right communication
i was shown in regard to the remnant
people of god
choosing a name two classes
were presented before me the one pla
class and grace the great bodies
of professed christians key word
professed
they were trampling upon god's law and
bowing to a papal institution
they were keeping the first day of the
week as the sabbath of the lord the
other class who were but few
in number were bowing to the great law
giver
they were keeping the fourth commandment
the peculiar
and prominent features of the faith were
the observance of the seventh day and
waiting for the appearing of our lord
from heaven sabbath second coming
seventh-day adventists
testimonies volume 1 page 223 paragraph
no name which we can take will be
appropriate
but that which accord with our
profession
expresses our faith and marks us
a peculiar people never join
any movement to change this name
let me continue with the quotation the
name several the adventist
is a standing rebuke to the protestant
world
here is the line of distinction between
the worshipers of god
and those who worship the beast and
receive his mark
you didn't get what i just said just the
name itself without a sermon being
preached
is a standing rebuke to the protestant
world
who claims sola scripture
that fancy word means the bible in the
bible alone
here is the line of distinction
where do you draw the line sever the
adventist
everybody else now that sounds
narrow but you need to understand i'm a
very narrow-minded man
the seventh day is the sabbath i am
narrow-minded about that
don't waste time telling me sunday and
tuesday
jesus is as equally god as is the father
i am
narrow minded about that
the world was created in six literal
days i
am now reminded about that who is narrow
minded with me can i see your hand ah
god bless you
the holy ghost is an intelligent being
fully divine
i am narrow-minded about that the
seventh-day adventist church is god's
remnant church on earth
i am narrow-minded about that who else
is now reminded about that
god bless you i am a narrow-minded man
all right if you discuss 144 000 i am
broad-minded
is it literal fine is it symbolic fine i
am just broad-minded say amen for
broad-minded uh-huh
is jesus coming back i am narrow-minded
[Music]
yes
here is the line of distinction between
the worshipers of god and those who
worship the beast and receive his mark
testimonies volume 1 page 2 24 paragraph
one
the name seventh-day adventist carries
the true
features of our faith up front out from
and will re convict the inquiring mind
the name alone causes people to think
like an arrow from the lord's quiver it
will wound the transgressors of god's
law
and will lead to repentance towards god
and faith in our lord jesus christ now i
know you missed that quotation
just the name can lead to repentance
what other church makes that claim
hold on to your seats i need lip balm
for this
this is a special declaration need some
lip balm
medical ministry page 49 paragraph four
write this down oh say sister
we have a little time i'll finish early
so it's okay
no no i'm fine medical ministry page 49
paragraph four
listen to words of inspiration that
perhaps you've never heard
if you've heard you forgot have we
written it down
or not yet medical ministry page what
did i say
49 what paragraph four
are you still writing sister do you have
a pen sister
does it have ink all right
we haven't got all night sister i'm a
nice man but we haven't got all night
are we ready medical ministry give me
the page
give me the paragraph here's what it
says
christ was a seventh-day adventist
to all intents and purposes
come on give me a livelier amen than
that huh
ben let me explain something for you in
our church we have a lady we consider to
be a prophet
and i'm quoting from her writings her
name is ellen white
as she examined the life of christ
how he lived what he preached
she concluded christ was a
seventh-day adventist to all
intents and purposes
so i belong to the church christ will
join if he walked on this earth
now if i understand that
why do i want to join another church
come on say amen for my friend
[Laughter]
this is serious business do you
understand the
insult to god when an israelite
wants to be an egyptian are you not
listening to me
and israelite wants to be a philistine
i won't identify the church but i have
met at least two young people who went
to one of those churches came back demon
possessed
another young man he went his possession
was different he just became a half of
an idiot
you know the father brought him to me i
was preaching in a certain country on
the face of the earth
and uh i was doing counseling one-on-one
in the day preaching at night
the father brought her son my son was
number one in the school this assembly
had with his father
he went to one of these unnamed people
for the preacher
the prophet to pray for him the fellow
put his hand on his head
lost his mind
let me tell you something if god says
babylon is fallen and you get in your
car and drive to babylon you deserve
what you get
there's a big mistake a lot of
adventists make they try to be too nice
and so we sacrifice truth in order to be
nice
now it's nice to be nice are you with me
but jesus says i came not to bring peace
but a sword
because you see if heaven is heaven and
the earth is the earth which is
the headquarters of satan whatever comes
from heaven will upset earth
truth enrages error righteousness
inflames sin
so when jesus said eat my flesh and
drink my blood and those men
misunderstood his words
he said does this offend you
and from that time many of the disciples
went back
and walked no more with him they did not
like what he said when all of them left
in a crowd he turned to the twelve and
said will he also go meaning
everyone else had left because
he said something they did not like
so what do young people tell me well i
go to those churches on sunday for the
spirit
and i come to the adventist church for
the word
is the spirit that helps you to
understand the word
if you get the wrong spirit on sunday
the following sabbath you don't
understand anything
well i've heard this we go for the
spirit
and we come to the church on sabbath for
the word
if the spirit convicts you of something
do you know how you test the genuineness
of that conviction
by the word
even the spirit has to be tested
not your conscience your conscience is
beautifully unreliable
unless it is educated by
the word listen to me you know uh was it
last year or the year before i was in
papua new guinea
years ago well known for headhunters and
people eating people
you know you fight your enemies you eat
your enemy that gives you strength
now in that culture that was no problem
for the conscience are you with me
so you just can't go by conscience you
go by the word
and the word says babylon is fallen
the word says come out not
go in
listen to me carefully
if you decide to leave the seventh-day
adventist church just don't go to church
is not a sign of intelligence
to leave this system of truth and go
this way
just forget church altogether
what is your name i'm a
seventh-day adventist
the church got its name from a divine
source
but before you begin patting yourselves
on the back
to whom much is given
now let me get on the dark side of being
an adventist
those of us who are unfaithful to our
mission
the bible tells them some people will be
beaten with few stripes
and some with many stripes
those who will be beaten with the most
stripes are those who have the most
privileges and abuse them
so before you puff your chest obama 70
adventists
ask yourself am i faithful to the
privileges
of this calling because we have a
message
the world needs and if we don't preach
it
people will die and their blood
yes because if the trumpet given
uncertain sound who shall prepare
himself to the battle
listen to me carefully it is better
never to have known the way of
righteousness
then after they have known it to turn
from the holy commandment committed unto
them second peter chapter 2 i think
verse 21.
it is a serious thing to be a
seventh-day adventist let me show you
how serious
the bible says in john 1 verse 10 he
came unto his own
and rizzo received him not the verse 11
verse 10 says
he was in the world and the world was
made by him
and the world knew him not verse 11 says
he came unto his own and his own
received him not now you combine those
two verses two things happened
verse 10 he came to the world he created
nobody knew him how is that possible
a group of people had been called by god
hundreds of years ago
their mission was to reflect god and
prepare the world
for the first coming of god because
christ is god
somebody say amen if christ isn't god he
cannot save you
but that's another story the jews
did not do their work
and so when christ came the one who said
let there be light
the one who spread the heavens because
god the father himself said
in hebrews 1 verse 10 and thou lord in
the beginning talking to the son
has laid the foundations of the earth
and the heavens are the works of thy
hands
when the creator came as a baby in a
manger
nobody knew except some wise men from
the east who traveled hundreds of miles
and a few shepherds who found out just
about that same night
that was it now this same god
is coming the second time
now he's not coming the second time to
save anybody
in other words he's not coming to preach
he's not coming to give you another
chance
he's coming to wrap it up
are you with me the first time he came
nobody knew
because a group of people did not do
the divinely appointed assignment which
is
warm the world
just before he comes he put together a
group of people
who are to want the world
prepare the world for his second coming
and the preparation
is found in revelation 14 the messages
of the first
second and third engine because right
after those messages is the coming of
christ
that group of people are seventh-day
adventists
what are we busy doing we want to be
pentecostals
we want to be rappers
we want to go on american idol
we want to be baptist
we want to be nothing
and christ is about to come
what is your name
you and i have a mission from god
to warn the world that christ
the creator the mighty god
is coming back and if you observe how he
comes back verse 14 revelation 14
and i looked and behold a white cloud
upon the cloud one sat like unto the son
of man having on his head a golden crown
not a mitre who or the mitre
the priest who intercedes right now
when christ takes off that mitre
lays off his priestly robes and puts on
his kingly robes and he comes back
he is not coming back to intercede
because he does not have a sensor in his
hand
waving the the instance of his merits he
has
a sickle
and he's coming to reap two harvests
revelation 16 and the angel thrust in
his sickle in the earth and the earth
was reaped
revelation 14 16 one harvest
second harvest and the angels thrusted a
sickle into the earth and guarded the
vine of the earth and cast it into the
great winepress of the wrath of god
verse 19 revelation 14 second harvest
if the second harvest goes into the
great winepress of the wrath of god
meaning destruction where does the first
harvest go
it's a book of opposites come on talk to
me those are the saved
but you'll observe both harvests
revelation 14 15 16 both harvests are
right
revelation 19 the second harvest is
right both are ripe
do you know what brings both harvest to
the rightness
the three angels messages
[Music]
but most of the world is still green and
god never picks green fruits
somebody joined my sister
god does not pick green fruits it's
unfair to the fruit to pick it green
are you with me
the messages that only seventh-day
adventists have you can listen to tdjs
from now until doomsday
by the way jesus died for him don't
misunderstand me you will
never hear a message on the three angels
messages
you know why it was not given to him
that's the simple reason he can go to
ten schools and get
ten doctoral degrees he cannot explain
that
unless he becomes
[Music]
somebody saying man now that i've
composed myself
you can listen to creflo dollar
until he becomes creflo penny and you
will
never hear a message about the three
angels
never why it was not given to him
unless he becomes one
and one of those that studies
oh sister have you ever spoken the truth
ah you know i love you say amen
i'm commanded to love you this is my
commandment that you love one another i
have no choice
you're looking at a man on the command i
love you i love you
but we need to wake up
you know the bible says and i'm
preaching many sermons in one this is my
last
hurrah jesus says
in matthew 6 33 but seek ye
first now when should you seek it first
when the economy is good
[Music]
when the economy is bad anytime
now when the economy goes bad people
leave god and go look for living
now come on you know that's true
no truth doesn't change because of
circumstance
seek ye first the kingdom of god
and his righteousness all
these things that man you want so badly
that wife you want so badly that seventh
child you want so badly
that other degree further studies
they all get ahead of the kingdom of god
and his righteousness you know if god
sent a message saying i'm coming in
three months people will rush to get
three things
a spouse a child and a degree
to take the heaven with them
[Applause]
three months to get me a man three
months to get a child in that time
three months to get another degree
those are our priorities now nothing is
wrong with any one of them don't get me
wrong
but when they come ahead
of priority one then you begin to
understand why jesus said
and as it was in the days of noah so
life shall it be also in the days of the
son of man
they did eat they drank they married
wives they were given in marriage he
said likewise also as it was in the days
of lot
they did it they drank they bought they
sold
they planted they builded none of those
eight things
is a sin
eat god invented eating drink
he invented he performed the first
married ceremony
he married and he gave in marriage
buying
selling planting building all
honorable activities but when they
occupy
the wrong position in the list of
priorities
they only prepare us for hell
jesus didn't say they were committing
fornication and adultery and robbing
banks and genocide
and raping little girls and knocking
over old ladies and stealing their
social security checks
he didn't say that
because it's too obvious
you fry for those things he targeted
the things that don't look obvious
another degree tying me up for seven
more years
this and that
and the world is dying
but if you say you love jesus everybody
loves jesus
let's make a commitment my brothers and
sisters
we are afraid that if we put god first
we miss everything
we don't read the text it says seek he
first
the kingdom of god and his righteousness
you finish the text
and all these things shall be added
all these things only have the proper
place when priority one is god's kingdom
and his righteousness
if that's not number one everything else
is in the wrong place and you and i
qualify for inclusion
in that group of which jesus says as it
was
in the days of noah
[Music]
young people you are at the
threshold of adulthood
you can with god's leading
chart of course for your life
that makes it clear to anyone watching
you
that god is your priority
i was talking to a young man several
years ago at a youth conference
and he said can i talk to i said yes we
sat down tears came to his eyes why are
you crying
you may have heard me told that story
tell that story before
when i pick up my bible my father kicks
it out of my hand
is your father adventist yes he's an
elder
why does he do that he says the bible
will not prepare you for the s.a.t
pick up your physics book
that father was not seeking the kingdom
first
he was not even concerned about his
son's eternal salvation
he was concerned about that boy getting
into a good school let's put good in
quotation marks
get a good job get a nice house
and just put down permanent roots on a
world that's dying
support a young lady i've told this
story before
i'd like to talk to you let's talk
what's the problem tears
why are you crying i begged my parents
send me to an adventist school
they said no the quality of education is
too low you need to go to high school
like harvard
a school with a name
she said they sent me to one of those
schools from the time i entered that
school
every foundational belief i've had was
shaken and i've got one foot in the
church one in the world and she's
crying
it's about a young lady from another
country on the face of the earth
she was working in a bank the bank
wanted her to work on sabot she said no
she kept writing me what should i do i
said don't work even if you have to live
under a tree
do not work
by the way if you're a doctor or nurse
or dentist and you work on sabbath give
the money to god so
yes that's what ellen white says
she went to her parents for comfort
and encouragement and strength
they said mommy and daddy they want me
to work on sabbath the parents are
adventists you know what the parents
said
you're young you have to establish
yourself
work
there's a man called abraham maslow
he developed a famous thing called the
hierarchy of needs
his theory is the most important thing
is self-preservation
and if that's not in place people have
no concern for the higher levels you see
there's self-preservation then there's
security then social needs and something
else
the highest being self-actualization and
if you look at esau
you can see that working people place
self-preservation against doing the will
above doing the will of god
above spiritual things above a place in
god's kingdom
and so when jacob said sell me this
they're thy birthright
in verse 32 genesis 25 esau said
behold i am at the point to die and
what prophet will this burst light be to
me
i need cottage i need food i need a
birthright
no value did he place on the spiritual
jacob gave him a bowl of soup he drank
it and that was the end of him
[Music]
do you see any profit in putting god
first in your life
you know what the rich people say in job
21 verse 14 verse 15 therefore listen to
god depart from us
we desire not the knowledge of thy ways
what is the almighty
that we should serve him and what profit
should we have
if we pray unto him what's the point in
being a faithful adventist
when i can go through the motions
and get some from the church and some
from the world
you may do that and no one may know
until
the day of judgment
well it'll be too late to change
i call upon you as your brother in
christ make
up your mind to be a seventh-day
adventist
a people raised up by god
to remind the world that there's
something called
the ten commandments
and that the god who spoke them from
sinai still requires them
today they reflect his righteousness
and they are the standard that qualifies
a person
for admission to the kingdom
tonight i recommit my life to god
i say father give me the strength
the heart the determination
the bullheadedness to preach this truth
even at the cost of my life
i want god to bring me to the place
where i just don't
care
if i get killed for preaching the truth
i want to come to the place where i
don't care
i'm asking you particularly my young
friends
now the devil wants you so badly so
badly he has youth he has strength he
has energy and all things being equal he
has many decades of life
deny him deny him
jesus said the thief cometh not but for
the steel to kill to destroy
don't take the side of a man trying to
kill you take the side of the one who
says and come that they might have
life and they might have it now more
abundant take his side
how many will say lord give me the mind
the heart the courage
to stand for you no matter what can i
see your right hand stand up with me
what is your name seventh-day adventist
i want you to stay standing let me
address my young brothers and sisters
every day recommit your life to god
our high calling page 215 paragraph two
ella white writes
genuine conversion is needed not once in
years
but daily if you're romantically
involved with nonsense advertise break
it off
tonight
to connect with an unbeliever is to
place yourself
on satan's ground that's inspired
counsel
let me say it again if you are
romantically connected to an unbeliever
break
it off please
follow the admission god the admonition
god gave the israelites and god said the
reason why i don't want you
intermingling
is because they will turn your heart
from me
put god first in everything you do put
him above your studies above your
romance
above everything because if that's not
the case then he's not your god
every day you wake up that's a brand new
lifetime because sleep is death
in the bible when we sleep at night
we're kind of dead
god in his mercy wakes us up that's a
brand new
lifetime fill it
with that which pleases the life-giver
make the word of god the cornerstone of
your intellect
counsels to the church page 207
paragraph 6 as a means of
intellectual training the bible is more
effective than any book
or all other books combined
and so i beg you young people i plead
with you
don't let the world dazzle you and twink
and cause your eyes to twinkle
keep your eyes on christ
because young people go to hell just
like the old
young will go to heaven just like the
old the choice
is yours let's pray
father in heaven if i preach badly
forgive me
you know my heart i just love to point
people to you
to call them to obey you by the power of
your spirit
now father let the messages heard this
weekend remain on the lives and the
hearts of those who heard
father let us leave determined to honor
you in all that we do
and because we're seventh-day adventist
father we know the sun has set
so the holy day has passed but the sun
does not set on our personal holiness
so let us guard what we plan to do
tonight
that we may honor you father let me say
how delighted i am that brother ben came
back to be with us
he is searching for truth as he reads
psalm 32 verse 8 i will instruct the
unteached in the way which thou shalt go
as he reads psalm 25 4 show me thy ways
of lord teach me thy paths
lead me in thy truth and teach me lead
that
son of yours to truth i remember as a
child god how my family and i sat around
the radio
listening to the sermons of herbert w
armstrong
but his sermons led us by your will to
the seventh-day adventist church
now i have a brother who's of the same
background
you lead him direct him guiding bless
his family
bless us the donor who came earlier
today continue to touch your heart
bless everyone who came dear god you
love to bless and so do what you love
and bless us keep us faithful
father save us when you come without
losing one
until that day help us to live lives so
that you can depend on us to be faithful
bless life bless fyi
in jesus name i pray amen
god bless